Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, for my first
Arrow winter break video I wanted to get into
some of the stuff we know about the back half
of the season.
We already know the general arc of The Black
Canary.
Some people are calling the next three episodes
the Canary Trilogy.
And Oliver has this really big Flashback storyline.
Which will feature Amanda Waller a lot more
prominently.
And yes, even though the DC movies and the
tv shows are officially separate universes.
I do think the Suicide Squad movie happening
so soon is going to have some influence on
the way the show can use those characters.
I’ll explain what I mean.
Let’s do Oliver first, because I know that’s
what everyone is going crazy about.
He is very clearly at the point of death,
so just as a way to side step his recovery
be it through use of Lazarus Pit or more traditional
means.
Stephen Amell can’t just totally check out
of the show for 4 or 5 episodes.
That’s where the flashbacks come in.
He’s been posting a crazy number of pictures
to Social Media that feature him with the
classic Flashback wig on.
But there was also this one of him with Robbie
Amell.
I don’t think Firestorm is going to go back
in time or anything.
I just think that Robbie Amell was visiting
the set.
Not to shoot any Firestorm scenes.
Arrow and The Flash share a production budget
and they also film on adjacent studio lots.
So the actors can walk over if and say hi
to each other if they have enough time.
As of Episode 9 all we know about Hong Kong
is that Maseo’s wife, Katana and their son
have been kidnapped by China White.
And she has a bioweapon.
So the real goal of the flashbacks for the
rest of the season are fixing those two problems.
Because of the way Maseo was acting in present
day.
It seemed like his wife and son died and he
wanted to leave his old life behind.
That’s why I think he said Maseo no longer
exists when Oliver first recognized him.
That doesn’t guarantee they die in the flashbacks,
but if they’re doing a version of Katana’s
origin story from the comics, then they have
to.
It’s just in Arrow’s version of events.
Maseo seems like he’s taken on the Katana
persona.
These are the titles of the next four episodes
and all the info we have on them.
But something really important to remember
is that Stephen Amell said in the back half
of the season, just like season 2, every four
episodes or so is it’s own self contained
storyline.
So there will be at least two or three big
arcs.
10 is
called Left Behind, 11 is called Midnight
City, 12 is Uprising, 13 is Canaries and 14
is The Return.
I’m mostly going to focus on what the producers
have said about the Flashback storylines and
the Black Canary and where I think those things
are headed.
The titles of the episodes usually reflect
things happening in present day and in the
flashbacks.
Left Behind is mostly a reference to Team
Arrow.
All the people Oliver leaves behind.
There’s this big christian novel series
about what happens to the survivors after
most of the world’s population gets raptured.
So if we do see Hong Kong scenes in this episode
I think they will be minimal.
But they do have to follow up on the big WTF
with China White taking Maseo’s family and
the bioweapon.
So they’ll tee up Amanda Waller’s plan
for cleaning up that mess.
But really I think the focus will be on the
surviving members of Team Arrow and how they
learn to continue Oliver’s mission when
he’s not around.
I’m really interested to see if Nyssa tells
them Oliver is dead.
She’s their only point of contact with the
League of Assassins.
So if they find out what happened right away.
It’s either from Nyssa or Merlyn.
I think Oliver not being around will create
a bit of a vacuum and crime will get a little
worse.
And that will kick Laurel into putting on
the Black Canary costume.
Like the way crime rates in Gotham double
when Batman isn’t around for an extended
period of time.
She will get the costume during the episode.
But because it’s a huge deal I think they’ll
save it for like a big third act reveal.
Another Batman Begins type thing.
Batman goes out without the cowl and no one
is afraid of him.
Laurel comes back at the end of the episode.
Puts the costume on and starts trying to scare
the shit out of people.
Then the next two or three episodes after
that is her Batman Year One story.
She gets her ass handed too her until she
gets her shit together to the point where
she can actually catch criminals without breaking
every bone in her body.
Stephen Amell was really clear that Laurel
wouldn’t just put the costume on and automatically
be Black Canary.
It’s going to be just like Roy.
It took him an entire season to figure it
out and Nyssa still beat the shit out of him
without breaking a sweat.
So even Roy still has a long way to go.
I’m really interested to see if Laurel compels
Wildcat to come back into action to help them
out.
It seems like it would be unfair for them
to tease that in the Boxing Glove episode
and not give us our Justice Society moment.
Midnight City Episode 11 could be a reference
to Doctor Mid Nite.
The writer who wrote this episode is the one
who also brought Doctor Mid Nite back in the
Green Arrow comics.
He was a member of the Justice Society.
I know I keep saying Justice Society on Arrow.
And I really think we’ll get there by the
end of the season.
Not in the traditional sense like they call
themselves Justice Society.
We’ll just get enough of those characters
on the show working together that it seems
like Justice Society.
Episode 12 Uprising could be the start of
Diggle and Lyla taking control of Argus.
Sin is returning too.
In know everyone wanted her to come back.
It seems like she’ll have been living in
the Glades this whole time.
I hope they explain why she lost touch with
Roy.
The actors said that they would being effectively
taking control of Argus from amanda waller
this season.
They didn’t say why, only that Waller would
have other priorities.
It could be a side effect of the Suicide Squad
movie, but they might also use it as an opportunity
for Amanda Waller to found a new team like
the Outsiders or some other team up they’ll
prep for season 4.
It’s also worth noting that Vinny Jones
will be in both Episode 11 and 12 as Brick
from the comics.
His name, Danny Brickwell also appeared on
Oliver’s List from Season 1.
Episode 13 Canaries is a big flashback episode.
It will tell the story of how Sara joined
the League of Assassins.
Maseo said that he joined at the same time
as Sara, so he’ll probably be in those episodes
too.
Caity Lotz is coming back.
She’ll be alive because everything is happening
in the past.
Episode 14 is the Slade Episode.
Manu Bennett came back but we don’t know
if it’s in present day or in a flashback.
And Marc Guggenhein was very specific that
the title “The Return” doesn’t refer
to Oliver’s return or Slade’s Return.
So take from that what you will.
Someone or something else is returning.
In that episode Marc Singer of Beastmaster
fame will be playing Matthew Shrieve from
the comics.
But he is confirmed as a flashback character.
In the comics he’s the head of the Creature
Commandos.
A US military team of supernatural creatures.
Shrieve is the only human on the team.
It’s supposed to be a big arc.
So we could see a flashback metahuman team.
In the new 52 comics they’re a SHADE team.
But it’s still the same deal, superhuman
military task force led by Frankenstein.
I’m not expecting to see frankenstein on
the tv show though.
But look out for easter eggs.
Episode 15 is called Nanda Parbat.
I’m hoping we get to see Oliver in Nanda
Parbat in present day.
But we could see team arrow member road trip
out there to try and bring him back.
Those are all the episodes we know about right
now.
That still leaves 7.
So there’s so much more that’s going to
happen.
Yes I do think Ray Palmer will fight with
Team Arrow, yes I do think Oliver will be
back in Starling in present day before the
last couple
of episodes.
Yes Merlyn will team up with Oliver at some
point.
And only for a very brief period.
Oliver still hates him.
And as for the DJ in the nightclub.
I don’t think he’s Joe, Deathstroke’s
son.
But I do think he’ll end up being a bigger
part of
the narrative.